- As Michael Myers spies on
his sister and her boyfriend
at the beginning of the movie,
you'll notice that the clown mask
actually belongs to the boyfriend,
or at least he found it there
and decided to incorporate it.
He brings it up with him
when the two decide to go upstairs.
This small detail may be the key
to understanding the entire film.
The opening scene is shown
through the perspective
of the six-year-old voyeur Michael Myers.
He's at an age where kids
are very impressionable.
What a child sees at this age
can shape who they become.
Children his age, also,
normally aren't capable
of understanding topics
of a mature nature.
He sees the boyfriend put on this mask
and kiss Judy with it,
then goes upstairs to do
something in the dark.
It is perhaps not the first time
Michael has seen something like this
without their knowledge of it,
but he wasn't supposed to see this
and he doesn't know any
better than to imitate it.
He grabs a phallic object
and takes it upstairs.
He comes across the mask
and puts it on himself,
just copying what he had
seen through the window.
When he enters the room,
he looks at Judy then looks
at the recently used bed,
then back at Judy.
This little camera movement suggests
that he probably has seen
the deed done before.
He uses the object against Judy,
then, as he had seen the
boyfriend do, immediately leaves,
goes down the stairs and goes outside.
For the first time we see
Michael and he's wearing
the red, yellow, green,
and blue clown costume,
which matches the red,
yellow, green, and blue shirt
that Judy's boyfriend had been wearing.
The trauma of that night's events
had all spawned from a
bad imitation of an act
that the child was never supposed to see,
and this experience would shape
everything that would happen
when Michael returned 15 years later.
To learn the meaning behind of
this and other iconic scenes
stick around to the end of this video.
(menacing music)
"Black cats and goblins
and broomsticks and ghosts,
covens of witches with all of their hosts,
You may think they scare
me, you're probably right,
black cats and goblins
on Halloween night."
Welcome to Things You Missed.
Yes, I'm finally doing Halloween.
Now as a disclaimer, there
are certain things that happen
in the Halloween sequels
that kind of recontextualize
what happens in this original movie.
But for this video, I'm just
gonna analyze the original
as a standalone movie
and you'll see why as we
get further into this.
For this series, I'll also be joined
by YouTube's resident's
Halloween expert, Jimmy Champane.
- What we now know is one of
horror's biggest franchises
started as a small, independent film
directed by John Carpenter.
There's not much I can say in this section
that hasn't already been covered
on plenty of other channels,
but I think you might be surprised
at some of the things you missed.
So let's jump back into them now.
(knives sharpening)
(ominous music)
- One of the best parts about Halloween
is that iconic soundtrack,
which kicks off at the
very beginning of the film,
where we see the opening titles
next to a Jack-o'-lantern.
You'll notice the cutouts
of the nose and mouth
are connected by this slice.
I've seen it suggested
that this makes it look like
somebody holding a knife.
I can kind of see that,
but I'm really more interested
in the camera movement
which pushes forward all the way
into the Jack-o'-lantern's left eye.
I see this as a foreshadowing
of the climax of the movie,
where Laurie used a coat hanger
to poke out Michael's left eye
so she can escape the closet.
I mentioned how Michael's youth
may have impacted his development
when it comes to mature topics.
As the admirable Spencer Charnas puts it
"Stabbing in the Dark".
Think about it.
There's more than one meaning there,
but both meanings are
intertwined by the matchbox
that Michael finds after
breaking out of the sanitarium
and into the station
wagon that he hijacks.
It says, "The Rabbit in Red Lounge".
Rabbits are often used as an adult symbol
while red, well, you've
seen a horror movie before,
you know what red stands for.
- Blood. It stands for blood.
- Yes. Thank you for your
insight, Jimmy Champane.
The horror genre has no
shortage of fictional towns
that fans would probably love to visit.
Maybe you'd like a creamy bowl
of clam chowder in Derry, Maine
or soak up some sun in Amity Island.
One of the most famous examples
is Halloween's own Haddonfield, Illinois.
Having lived in Illinois as a kid,
go Cubs, go,
I was curious about where
Haddonfield is located.
- I always liked this location a lot
because it's pretty close to the place
where I grew up in Southeast, Michigan.
- When attempting to pick up Michael,
the nurse asks why they're
taking him up to Harden County.
Haddonfield, Maine may
not be a real place,
but Harden County is,
which means the story must take place
way down at the bottom tip of the state.
However, both direct sequel
show police paraphernalia
from Warren County, which
is all the way to the west.
While "Halloween 4" places
the town in Livingston County,
closer to the Northeast by Chicago.
I think the idea is that Haddonfield
is just supposed to be a stand in
for any small town in America.
The kind of every town USA ordeal.
- Of course, I don't think
there's anywhere in Illinois
that has outdoor schools or palm trees
so it's probably best not to
focus on the location too much.
In fact, the name Haddonfield
actually comes from the
writer-producer of the movie,
Deborah Hill's hometown, which
was Haddonfield, New Jersey.
And on top of that, the name Michael Myers
comes from the European distributor
who put out Carpenter's previous film
"Assault on Precinct 13"
and made sure it was an
international success
because, you know, naming
an immortal serial killer
after someone is the most
sincere form of flattery,
and on a completely unrelated side note,
I fully expect your first slasher villain
to be named after me.
- I guess nobody told that
to the character of Michael Myers though,
because as I mentioned earlier,
he still thinks that imitation
is the most sincere form of flattery.
Just as he did 15 years ago,
he finds himself a costume
before going on his next rampage.
Once again, he chooses a
one-piece jumpsuit and a mask,
but this time the jumpsuit
is a mechanics attire
instead of the clown suit,
and the mask is a heavily
modified Shatner mask
stolen from the hardware store.
- Although or maybe
because William Shatner
would have been instantly
recognizable back in 1978,
they made a ton of
alterations to the mask,
like painting the skin stark white,
dying the hair brown and
widening the eye holes.
It basically removed
every identifiable feature
from the mask, which,
if you think about it,
is perfect for a character named The Shape
who's literally the
absence of all character.
- Given the psychosexual subtext
that I've highlighted for this character,
it's probably no coincidence
that he chooses to
imitate a male heartthrob
from a popular TV series.
One who happens to have given
one of the most noteworthy onscreen kisses
in television history.
The psychosexual metaphors
do not end there though.
This theme touches many
aspects of the film,
like in this scene where Laurie
Strode is walking to school
while singing a little song to herself.
♪ I wish I had you all alone, ♪
♪ Just the two of us ♪
- Notice how when
Michael steps into frame,
we can hear his heavy
breathing against the mask
as he stares her all the
way down the sidewalk.
(Michael heavy breathing)
(birds chirping)
Of course, at the end of the movie,
we would later find that her idea
of being all alone with a man
is far different than his idea
of being all alone with her
or any of the other
babysitters he would encounter
in the neighborhood.
But before we get there,
there is an interesting scene
in Laurie's English class
that we can analyze to learn more
about Michael Myers' true nature.
(thunder rumbling)
(ominous music)
- [Teacher] No matter what
course of action Collins took,
he was destined to his own fate.
His own day of reckoning.
(ominous music)
- As Laurie sits in the
back of her English class,
her teacher gives a lecture about fate
and she asked the class to compare
two authors' different portrayals of it.
Laurie answers that one author, Costaine,
saw fate as being related to religion
while the other Samuels saw
it as a natural element.
The teacher then expands
upon Laurie's answer.
- [Teacher] That's right.
Samuels definitely personified fate.
In Samuels's writing, "Fate
is immovable like a mountain.
It stands where man passes away.
Fate never changes."
- After watching the movie a few times,
this interpretation
starts to sound familiar.
It's almost as if the English teacher
is talking about Michael
Myers who Laurie briefly spots
out the window during the scene.
Michael is the personification of fate.
Michael is literally this immovable force
that will end the lives of nearly anyone
that he sets his sights on.
Throughout the movie, Dr.
Loomis raves about how Michael
has nothing but evil
behind his empty eyes.
He is the only one who fully understands
the threat that Michael represents.
If Michael was the
personification of fate,
then Loomis is essentially
the author Samuels
warning everyone that
fate is coming for them.
- [Jimmy] Perhaps another
clue to this metaphor
comes from the name of the
character, Dr. Samuel Loomis,
who side note is my favorite character
in the Halloween franchise.
The names of these two
authors seem fictional
or at the very least,
they're not obvious to us as the audience
when the teacher mentions the
name Samuels and Costaine.
Because of that, it's
extremely likely that Samuels
and Sam Loomis having very similar names
was an intentional clue.
There's another potentially
noteworthy point
about Sam Loomis that I
think is worth mentioning.
If you look at Alfred
Hitchcock's 1960 classic Psycho,
there's a character named Sam Loomis.
Normally, I don't think this
will be worth bringing up
in a video, but there are
a few other connections
to Psycho in Halloween.
So in Psycho, the character Sam Loomis
sleeps with the character Marion Crane
and in Halloween, there's a
character named Sam Loomis
who hangs out with a
character named Marion.
Her name is Marion Chambers,
but it's still Marion.
And then you got to
think about the fact that
Marion Crane is played
by Janet Leigh in Psycho
and Janet Leigh is Jamie Lee Curtis's mom.
Jamie Lee Curtis plays the main character
in Halloween, Laurie Strode.
And finally the lighting in Halloween
is clearly inspired by
the lighting in Psycho.
There are many scenes in Halloween
where you see characters striped in shadow
like the light is coming through blinds
or other horizontal objects.
- [ZAC] Then there's a broader connection
with the film's antagonist.
Spoiler alert for Psycho
until the end of this chapter.
Michael Myers and Norman
Bates are both disturbed
by mental conditions
acquired in their youth.
They both seem to be affected
by an Oedipus complex
or at least some variation of it.
Norman develops this
complex for his mother
while Michael vents his
developmental issues
into his sister, Judith.
Although Judith was his first target,
all we really know is
that she's a teenager
and it seems to be her
activity with her boyfriend
that sets Michael off.
When he returns to Haddonfield
on Halloween in 1978,
his attack pattern continues.
He claims for human victims in this movie
and comes after a fifth, which is Laurie,
but she's able to evade him.
The first was the mechanic,
which was off screen.
We can't really analyze that one.
The other three are
sexually active teenagers,
just like Judith was.
In fact, these girls hardly
seem to think about anything
besides hooking up.
At one point when Laurie mentioned
that she forgot her Chemistry book,
Lynda raves about how she
never brings her books home
because she doesn't need them.
She's a liar though.
She does have two books with her;
"One Love Forever" and
"Tender Love..." something.
We don't really get a
good look at this one.
The girl's priorities are clear.
Laurie prioritizes her future
by wanting to study and get good grades.
Lynda is more interested
in love and getting busy.
You could say that they
represents the Liberation Movement
that was going on from
the 1960s to the 1980s,
where traditional codes of
conduct were being challenged.
Laurie represents the
traditional point of view.
She's always covered up and
very modest about herself.
Her friends are, well,
the opposite of that.
They look for any excuse
to be a little bit more promiscuous.
Have you ever seen someone
completely strip down
and throw their entire outfit in the wash
after a small spill?
When Annie is in her underwear,
Laurie is actually adding on layers.
She puts on an apron while
getting a pumpkin with the kids.
Annie has a cigarette in the car.
She easily inhales it but
Lori chokes on the smoke
showing us that she's not
used to breathing in poison.
She is innocent and pure.
These girls are wired
with teenage hormones.
The difference is that Lynda and Annie
are acting on their urges
while Laurie keeps them internalized.
- God, I've got a shirt on.
That's all you ever think about.
- [Paul] I think it's
all you ever think about.
- That's not true. I think
about lots of things.
Now, why don't we not stand
here talking about them
and get down to doing them?
- [Zac] Annie even teases Laurie
for not being totally consumed
with dating like she is.
- Laurie dear, he wants to talk to you.
He wants to take you out tonight.
- We come to find out
that Laurie actually does have a crush.
She just doesn't see herself
as part of this whole liberation movement.
When Annie tells her she could
ask someone to the dance,
she literally says...
- You could do that. I couldn't.
I even found myself wondering
if the book that Laurie
forgets, her Chemistry book,
is an intentional comment
about her character.
Her two friends have boyfriends
but Laurie is single.
She hasn't developed that
chemistry with a man yet.
- [JIMMY] Writer-director John Carpenter
and writer-producer Debra Hill
have given many interviews over the years
where they clarified that
it was never their intent
to have the main character's survival
be mainly because she stays a virgin
throughout the entire film.
With that being said, though,
they've also attributed Laurie's
survival to her alertness,
whereas her friends are
distracted with horny endeavors.
I guess they're saying that
because it adds a little bit
of nuance to their writing
and they are totally within
their right to do so.
But to me, it's all the same.
It's kind of obvious that
Michael is trying to recreate
his sister's final night
with other lust-driven teens,
and it's Laurie's lack of beguilement
that helps her survive till the end.
And just for some quick trivia,
Jamie Lee Curtis has
talked about in interviews
that she was actually kind of
surprised that she was cast
as the goody two-shoes
character of Laurie Strode
because in real life,
she was actually more
like Annie and Lynda.
- This makes sense if we
analyze Michael's behavior.
When school first lets out,
one of the elementary kids,
Richie, runs into Michael.
There's an ample
opportunity to take him out
but he just lets him run along.
There were two moments
when Michael seems to eye Tommy Doyle
as he walks home from school,
but ultimately just moves on.
He's not James Charles.
He doesn't seem interested in little boys.
Although Tommy and Lindsey
are afraid of the boogeyman,
there's never a moment where
he actually pursues them.
It was always about sticking his knife
into Haddonfield High School's
most promiscuous teens.
I mean, look how he's holding
the knife right there.
I mean, come on.
- It's never really been
confirmed one way or the other,
which I kind of like.
But the leading theory as to why Michael
is trying to go after
teenagers to be his victims
is because they remind him of
his sister and her boyfriend.
Oh, and he also thinks they're all unpure,
which is why he can go after
Laurie Strode who's a virgin.
- Loomis and Sheriff Brackett are worried
about the safety of the
town's trick-or-treaters,
but this never turns out to be a problem.
Even though this kid
doesn't have a costume.
I mean, what the hell kid? It's Halloween.
You got to get yourself a costume.
Michael's Freudian issues
aren't just about who he's going after,
it's also how he's going about it.
But before we get there, there
are some important secrets
to decipher in Laurie's room.
(thunder rumbling)
(ominous music)
When the girls get out of school,
you can hear the cheerleaders
practicing in the background.
"We're from Haddonfield,
couldn't be prouder.
Can't hear us now we'll
yell a little louder."
I see this cheer is a foreshadowing
of that evening's events,
where there would be
quite a lot of yelling
from Haddonfield's student body.
- Help!
Help me please!
- The second line,
"Can't hear us now we'll
yell a little louder"
also fits in nicely with the screams
that finally get Dr. Loomis's attention.
The ground is dry, the ground is dry,
and the ground is wet.
Laurie goes home where we
see, for the only time,
the inside of her room.
Those of you who are
familiar with my videos
will probably expect me to point out
this Raggedy Ann doll on her dresser.
While it is true that this
is the same kind of doll
as the supposedly haunted doll
that inspired the Annabelle movies.
And while it is also true
that Ed and Loraine Warren
investigated the doll in 1970,
say, eight years before
Halloween came out,
I'm not entirely sure if John Carpenter
put it in the movie just to be creepy
or if it was just a
popular doll at the time.
All I can really say with
certainty is that this doll,
seen later at the Wallace's
house, is way creepier.
(scary music)
Laurie has a large poster of
a painting by James Ensor,
a Belgian expressionist
painters from the 1800s
who was most famous for
portraying human figures
wearing grotesque masks.
That may not seem like
much of a connection today
when masked horror movie
killers are plentiful,
but you have to remember
when Halloween came out,
Michael Myers wearing a mask
was kind of a novel concept.
This was the movie that started the trend.
Laurie looks out the window
and sees Michael standing
behind some bedsheets on a clothesline.
There seems to be a running theme
of Michael appearing behind
sheets and bedsheets,
which again, all ties into
the psychosexual themes
that I pointed out throughout this video.
When Annie sees Michael
in the laundry room,
it's through a sheet
and when he appears to
Lynda in the bedroom,
he's wearing a bedsheet ghost costume.
So we have all of these associations
tying Michael's appearances to the idea
of going to bed with someone.
And since I failed to bring
this up in my "It" 1990 episode,
I have to mention this here.
The production designer
and editor of Halloween
was Tommy Lee Wallace.
He went on to direct Halloween 3
but he also went on to direct It,
where he once again,
used a line of bedsheets
blowing in the wind for a scare.
Also, it looks like the guy
has like at least three
characters named after him;
Tommy Doyle, Leigh Brackett
and Lindsey Wallace.
- [JIMMY] That afternoon Loomis heads over
to Judith Myers' grave
site correctly assuming
that Michael will try to
go there at some point.
But unfortunately for him,
the grave keeper talks his ear off.
- You know, every town there's
something like this happens.
I remember over in Russellville.
Old Charlie Bowles. About 15 years ago.
- He tells the story of a guy
who went into his garage one night
and grabbed the hacksaw
and then came inside
and presumably turned his
family into mincemeat.
Back in 2014, John
Carpenter did an interview
with "Halloween Daily News"
where he described why he put
this weirdly specific story
in the movie.
Apparently, Russellville
was a city in Kentucky
near where John went to college
and old Charlie Bowles was named
after the father of his girlfriend
who was in the Kentucky mafia,
which I literally just found out existed,
and apparently, that guy
had her husband whacked.
In-laws. Am I right?
Anyway, they find Judith's
grave already uprooted
when they get there.
- [Taylor] They'll do
anything for Halloween.
- Guilty as charged.
- Loomis's next stop
is the old Myers house,
which has gained a reputation
for being supposedly haunted.
Now, this next one isn't a
traditional thing you missed,
but it's more something that
nobody talks enough about.
Loomis and Sheriff Brackett
discovered the remains of a dog
and realized the body is fresh,
and this is Dr. Loomis's response?
- He got hungry.
- [ZAC] So Michael got
hungry and pulled a RiceGum?
This is the most messed
up thing in the movie
and nobody ever talks about it.
So I just had to bring it up and ask, why?
Also, when they go upstairs,
the wallpaper is different
than it was in 1963.
We know that nobody lived
there after the Myers
so that means that Mr. and Mrs. Myers
actually tried to change the wallpaper
and continue living there
alone after Judith was killed
and Michael was sent to the sanitarium.
My personal head canon says,
"They thought they could
get past the trauma
of what happened there if they
change the look of the room,
but ultimately it was too sad
and they ended up abandoning
the house anyway."
- [JIMMY] That evening, Laurie
and Annie gets settled in
as the two are babysitting at houses
right across the street from each other.
And what I can only imagine
is the 1978 version of iPad parenting,
Laurie puts a movie on the TV
called The Thing from Another World,
which came out back in 1951.
It's a real movie
and it was one of John
Carpenter's biggest inspirations.
And it was kind of a preview
of things to come for him
because in 1982, he would
release his own remake of it,
which was just shortened to The Thing.
- Yeah, I think that one
sounds vaguely familiar.
- And just like with Halloween,
Big Trouble in Little China, The Fog,
and pretty much every
other John Carpenter movie,
when it came out, it was a
critical and commercial bomb,
but then as the decades went on,
it became revered as a classic.
Can you see why all John Carpenter
really seems to want to do these days
is sit inside and play Fallout?
- Why the glum face?
I thought random murder
was routine around here.
- [ZAC] As Laurie and
Annie talk on the phone
about the possibility of
attending the homecoming dance
with her crush, Ben Tramer,
Michael appears outside the
house for the first time.
At the beginning of the movie,
we saw Michael spying on
a teenage relationship
from his point of view,
but now we're seeing the other side
as Tommy notices The Shape
is standing in the dark
outside of the Wallace's house.
- Michael's many background appearances
are one of the things
that makes this movie
so fun to revisit year after year.
Every time they release
it on a new medium,
like DVD, Blu-ray, or 4k Blu-ray,
someone manages to find
him in a different spot
and I love that.
- Yeah, Jimmy, I can't wait
until you see this movie
after you upgrade from
seeing it on LaserDisc.
Just as bedsheets have served as a link
between Michael and the
things we do in the dark,
well, darkness is also a reminder
of that thing we do in the dark.
Now you're probably
reaching for that button
to click off this video
because almost all horror
movies take place in the dark.
Right?
Well, hold on just a minute.
It's not just the darkness here.
Although lighting wise,
this movie is really dark.
There are scenes where the
screen is almost entirely black.
You could say this is just a result
of this being a low budget
horror movie shot on film,
but it's not just a couple of scenes.
There are a lot of scenes
with barely any lights.
Two, the darkness is acknowledged
in the dialogue by Lynda.
- Hey, it's totally dark.
- Yeah.
- And three, what happens in
the dark is also relevant here.
For example, the screams in this movie.
They aren't your typical
blood curdling horror movie screams.
They almost sound more
like something else.
(girl squealing)
(car horn blaring)
(ominous music)
(girl squealing)
(closet rattling)
When Laurie hears Annie trying
to scream over the phone,
she even kind of acknowledges
that it sounds like there were
some extra-curricular activities
going on.
- All right, Annie.
First, I get your famous chewing,
now I get your famous squealing.
- That's not even all of them.
Next time you watch the movie,
that's something you can look out for.
But it's not just the
screams, I'm also gonna look
at how some of these kills are executed
and I'll be analyzing what the ending
of John Carpenter's
Halloween really represents.
(ominous music)
(thunder rumbling)
Keeping on topic with my main thesis
about Michael's rampage,
being a release of distorted
psychosexual attention,
let's look at the death scenes
of each of Laurie's friends
and see how they tie in to this idea.
The first to go is the Sheriff's
daughter, Annie Brackett.
Michael ambushes her when
she hops into the car
to go pick up her boyfriend,
but she realizes something is wrong
when she notices that the
windows are fogged up,
a sign that somebody had
been breathing inside
of the enclosed airspace for some time.
Anyone who had a high
school or college girlfriend
is probably familiar with the concept
of the fogged up car window.
Since teens usually don't have
a good place to get intimate,
they often end up driving a car
to a secluded location for some privacy.
So it's probably an intentional choice
for Michael to replicate that,
and the fact that she was on her way
to pick up her boyfriend
certainly fits with the
pattern of Michael's attacks.
- Someone smart like Laurie
probably would have realized
that somebody is in the car.
- [Zac] The next victims would be Lynda
and her boyfriend, Bob.
It really bothers me how Bob
just leaves the car door open
when they first pull up to the house.
- Yeah, why does he do that?
- The way he stalks
them is very reminiscent
of Michael's childhood Halloween in 1963.
He watches them make out on the couch
and he continues to spy on them
after they move things upstairs.
Notice his shadow passing by right here.
In a break from their activities,
Bob goes to the kitchen
to get a couple of drinks
and Michael uses a knife
to literally pin him up to the wall,
which symbolizes another
teenage cliche: pin-up models.
If you're somehow unfamiliar,
a pin-up is just a poster
of an attractive model or celebrity
that teens like to pin up
onto their bedroom wall
so they can fantasize about
them as they go to sleep.
The last kill of the movie is Lynda.
When Michael approaches her
and he's wearing a costume,
which leads her to believe that
this is her boyfriend, Bob.
This one represents role-play.
- What's the matter? Can't I
get your ghost, Bob? (laughs)
- Maybe it's cause I was born in the 90s,
but I still don't get why that's funny.
I think there's also something to be said
about how easy it is for Michael
to trap and kill these three
who were established to be the
most likely to be distracted
by the allure of hooking up,
as opposed to Lori who is
much more level-headed.
At times, it feels like Michael Myers
almost doesn't want to kill her.
It seems like he intentionally
misses her right here
and cuts her shirt instead.
Then again later, she's not moving,
yet he sticks the knife
into the couch instead.
In the context of the
message of the movie,
it's like he's giving her a warning.
He knows she has dirty thoughts
as established in the
car early that afternoon,
but her mind isn't consumed by dating
and boys like the others.
So taking her out doesn't really fit in
with Michael's agenda.
The chase continues on to
the Doyle's upstairs bedroom.
Laurie thinks that she's
gotten the better of Michael,
but in the background,
he can be seen rising up once more
in a manner very similar to Nosferatu
from the 1922 classic German horror movie.
Some might say there's a
phallic parallel going on here.
Loomis shows up in buries some
lead into his former patient
knocking him off the balcony.
But when he goes to collect his spoils,
the mysterious villain has disappeared.
The movie ends as the iconic score
shows us various locations
all around the house
accompanied by the slow
unnerving breathing
of the evil antagonist.
The final shot takes us back once more
to the Myers house as if to suggest
that this entire series of events
was just another mental episode.
Just like the one that
young Michael Myers went on
all of those years ago.
- I think the reason
Halloween has endured so long
is because at its heart,
it's a simple story
about a local boogeyman
coming back to haunt a
town on Halloween night
that could be any town in America.
The decision to have him
escape into the night
at the end of the movie was so smart
because if he's alive,
that means he's out there
and he could come to your
town on Halloween night
and you could have a run in with him.
That's what kept me up
at night when I was a kid
and some of the revelations in Halloween 2
also kept me up at night,
but for completely different reasons.
- Thanks to Jimmy Champane for joining me
in this analysis of Halloween.
Jimmy is all about Halloween
and other iconic slasher franchises.
So if you can't get enough blood and guts,
definitely go check out
his videos and subscribe.
We'll be back next week
with the next episode.
So if you love Halloween, the
holiday or the movie series,
you're in the right place.
Tap that playlist on
the left for more videos
and make sure you subscribe to CZsWorld
for new horrors every week.
Ring the death bell for all notifications
and I'll see you in the next one,
assuming we both survive.